المترجم: Ismail Al-Jubbah
المدقّق: Abd Al-Rahman Al-Azhurry
مرحباً
هدوء رجاءاً
أين الحضور ؟
أخبروا زملائكم أن الحضور اليوم
بثلاثة علامات
أيها الطالب !
قم بتمرير ورقة الحضور
وصلنا إلى الفصل الرابع
مقدمة
يعتبر التواصل الاجتماعي بين المدرس والطالب
داخل وخارج المحاضرة
أحد أهم عوامل نجاح العملية التدريسية
أ
أ- داخل المحاضرة:
ينبغي على المدرس أن يراقب أعين الطلاب
والتواصل معهم بشكل شفهي
ومحاولة إيجاد جو تفاعلي
بين المدرس والطلاب
مثلاً، لا ينبغي على المدرس قراءة المحاضرة
من كتاب أو من شرائح ضوئية
ب - خارج المحاضرة :
ما تبقى من المحاضرة
مقرر عليكم، اقرأوها بأنفسكم
(ضحك وتصفيق)
هل أحببتم هذا المدرس؟
كنت طالباً من قبل ولم أكن أحبه.
ولما أصبحت أستاذاً،
قررت أن لا أكون مثله.
في أول محاضرةٍ لي،
حاولت جاهداً أن أحضر لها بشكلٍ جيد،
وأن أركز على التفاصيل وأنسقها.
وفي داخل المحاضرة
قدمت بكل إخلاص.
وعندما نظرت في أعين الطلاب،
كانو جميعاً هكذا.
كان هناك طالب وحيد منتبه،
وكان منكوش الشعر،
سألته: هل يوجد أي سؤال ؟
فأجاب: ماذا نستفيد من كل هذا الكلام ؟
(ضحك)
استنتجت أن التحضير الجيد
ليس كافياً لدفع الطلاب للدراسة.
يجب أن أحاول زرع الحافز داخل الطالب.
يجب أن أجعله متحمساً ومتشجعاً
ليدرس بإخلاص.
في الدرس اللاحق،
بدلاً من أن تكون المحاضرة
عبارةً عن محاضرة برمجة عادية
جعلت المحاضرة عبارةً عن برمجة فايروسات.
تراااااا
أصبح جميع الطلاب متحمسين
لمعرفة كيفية برمجة هذا الكائن الغريب.
أصبح جميع الطلاب
مهتمين ومنتبهين إلى المحاضرة.
وسلم جميعهم المشاريع
في نهاية الفصل الدراسي إلا طالبين،
لم يحضروا المحاضرات، ولم يسلموا مشروعهم.
أصبح لدي دافع لأحفز هذين الطالبين
وأحمسهما لتسليم المشروع.
اتصلت بهما، وأخبرتهما أنني أنتظرهما
في مقهى معين، وأن يأتيا لتسليم المشروع.
وعندما أتيا، بدأت بأسئلتي عن المشروع،
ولم يستطيعا الإجابة
لأنهما قاما بنقل المشروع من زملائهما.
فأصبحت أشرحه لهما،
كما قمت بإعادة المادة لهما خلال 3 ساعات،
و قدمت لهما عصيراً،
وأصيبا بالخجل الشديد،
كان لسان حالهما يقول:
لماذا هذه العناية الفائقة!؟
ولكني لاحظت أنه وفي الفصول اللاحقة
وفي المواد التي درستها
كانا مهتمين بالحضور
ومهتمين بتسليم الوظائف والمشروع،
وأصبحا متميزين.
لاحظت أن الاهتمام الفائق
والعناية الفائقة بالطالب
تساعد وتنعكس على الطالب
حتى يهتم هو أيضاً بالمادة
أصبحت أتواصل مع الطلاب بشكل أكبر
عن طريق
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وأصبحوا يسألونني عن الوظائف والمشاريع.
مع الوقت سعيت لإزالة الحاجز
بين المدرس والطلاب
حاولت أن أكون صديقاً لهم
وليس كأي مدرسٍ عادي.
ولأن ما يهمني هو إفادة هؤلاء الطلاب،
أنشأت موقعاً الكترونياً،
ورفعت عليه المحاضرات.
وأصبحت أرفع عليه وظيفةً دوريةً
يجب على الطالب أن يسلمها بشكلٍ أسبوعي.
مما يساعد الطالب على عدم انتظار
آخر محاضرة في نهاية الفصل
أو في آخر أسبوعين
لتسليم المشروع أو لدراسة كل المادة.
التعليم بحاجة إلى التدرج.
وليس بشكلٍ مكثَّفٍ في آخر أسبوعين
لكي لا ينسى الطالب هذه المعلومات.
لذا، قام جميع الطلاب بتسليم كل الوظائف
ولكن ظهرت مشكلة بالنسبة لي،
بدأ جميع الطلب بسؤالي عن طريق الـFacebook
فعند عودتي للمنزل لآخذ قسطاً من الراحة،
وتبدأ الأسئلة،
"أستاذ! كيف نستطيع حل هذا؟"
"أستاذ! كيف نتجاوز هذه المشكلة؟"
"أستاذ! لم تتنجح معي؟"
"أستاذ! أقسم أنها معقدة !"
صار عليي بذل جهدٍ مضاعفٍ
لأجيبهم جميعاً.
ولأقلص من عدد الأسئلة،
فكرت في تسجيل المحاضرة كفيديو
لساعة ونصف ثم أرفعها على الإنترنت،
وهكذا يستطيع الطالب مراجعتها بنفسه.
ومع ذلك، استمرت الحالة نفسها،
"أستاذ! كيف نستطيع حل هذا؟"
"أستاذ! لا ادري ما أفعل!"
"أستاذ! أستاذ!"
علمت السبب عندما أخبرت أحد الطلاب
أن يقوم بمراجعة الفيديو،
فأجابني بأنه طويلٌ جداً!
هذا صحيح.
تكمن المشكلة في أن مدة الفيديو
طويلةٌ جداً لساعةٍ ونصف،
ويمر الطالب في داخل المحاضرة
بمراحل من التركيز والتشتت،
لذا قمت بمراجعة
الدورات الموجودة على الإنترنت،
لاحظت أن المحاضرة عبارةٌ
عن مجموعة فيديوهاتٍ قصيرةٍ،
وكل فيديو مخصصٌ لفكرةٍ
واحدةٍ من المحاضرة،
فالمحاضرة تتألف
من مجموعة فيديوهات مجزئة.
لذا قمت بنفس الفكرة،
جزأت المحاضرة إلى فيديوهات.
عند عودتي إلى المنزل،
أقوم بتجزيء المحاضرة إلى أفكار وأنسقهم،
مما اضطرني إلى اختصار الأفكار،
كي لا تتجاوز مدة الفيديو 6 الى 9 دقائق،
وأسجلها ثم أرفعها على الإنترنت.
مما عاد علي بالفائدة أولاً،
لأنني كمدرس أصبحت
أشاهد نفسي في أعين الطلاب،
وأصبحت ألاحظ أن هناك أفكاراً
كان يجب أن أشرح أمثلتها بطريقة مختلفة،
وأفكاراً كانت بحاجة لاختصار،
وأفكاراً يمكنني إيجاد مثال أفضل عنها،
مما ساعدني على تطوير نفسي،
وساعدني في تنسيق المحاضرات بشكل أفضل.
في المقابل أيضاً
أصبح الطلاب يهتمون أكثر وأكثر،
لأنهم أصبحوا يفهمون المحاضرات بشكل أفضل،
وبالتالي انخفض عدد الأسئلة
وانخفض عدد الطلاب الذين يتصلون بي
ليسألوني عن الوظائف والمذاكرات.
ولأقوم بزيادة رغبة الطلاب،
ولأظهر لهم تقديري لجهودهم،
وأشعرهم باهتمامي الشديد بما بذلوه من جهد،
أصبحت أوزع عليهم جوائز.
من يقوم بحل هذه الوظيفة له جائزة معينة،
ومن يقوم بحل هذه المذاكرة له جائزة معينة،
حتى لو كانت جائزة رمزية.
لم أتوقع
أن يهتم الطلاب بهذه الجوائز،
ولكني تفاجأت بأن الطلاب
تحفزوا وأصبحوا يتنافسون للحصول عليها.
بالنسبة إليهم هي علامة
احترامٍ من المدرس لهم،
بالنسبة إليهم هي تعبيرٌ
عن تقدير المدرس لعملهم.
بغض النظر عن العلامات.
وبحكم عملي في الجامعة وفي شركة برمجية
لاحظت أنه مازال هنالك فجوة
بين الحياة الأكاديمية والحياة العملية.
وفي محاولة مني لتقليص هذه المسافة
اتفقت مع رئيس الجامعة ورئيس الشركة
أن نأخذ مجموعةً من الطلاب
ونوفر لهم تدريباً في الشركة،
والمفاجئ أن بعض الطلاب
كانوا أفضل من بعض موظفي الشركة،
وقامت الشركة بالاحتفاظ بهم كموظفين.
وبالاضافة إلى أن أحد الطلاب
قام بتسليم المهمة التي طلبت منه
في الشركة كمشروع أكاديمي في الجامعة
مما حفزني جداً،
كما تُعد تجربةً ناجحة بالنسبة لي.
الفكرة لأنه يجب علينا تشجيع ذلك،
وأن نشجع الجامعات على
إنشاء مكاتب خاصة للتعاون مع الشركات،
لتقليص المسافة ما بين الطالب
والحياة الأكاديمية.
يوجد نقطة ثانية
وجدت أنه من المهم التركيزعليها،
حيث لا يتوقف الأمر
على اهتمام المدرس بالطالب،
بل يتعداه لاهتمام الطلاب ببعضهم.
فأصبحت أحاول أن أزرع
روح التعاون بين الطلاب.
أصبحت أحاول أن أحفزهم للعمل مع بعضهم.
فجعلت تسليم المشاريع والوظائف
وحتى الامتحان يجب أن يتم كفريق.
مما يساعد الطلاب على تدريس بعضهم
وأن يتحمسوا ويتشجعوا مع بعضهم.
بالإضافة إلى أن الطالب الجيد
سيغطي على الطالب الضعيف،
حتى يساعده ليصبح في مستواه.
وفي المقابل أيضاً لدينا الكثير
من المبادرات الجيدة للتعاون بين الطلاب
كمبادرة ويكيلوجيا Wikilogia
وفورنيوهمك For new HAMAK
حيث يقوم طلاب بشكل تطوعي ومجاني
بتدريس ومساعدة بعضهم البعض،
وإقامة محاضرات وورشات عمل،
مما لا يدل على نقص في الجامعة،
ولكن على نضج في المجتمع،
ويساعد على نضج الطالب
من الناحية الأكاديمية والاجتماعية
وأنا واقفٌ أمامكم الآن
لأن طلابي يعتقدون أنني أستاذٌ جيد.
شكراً.
(تصفيق)